I'm going to start with congrats on the
movie thank you very much so look I know
it's hard to talk about this kind of a
film because you don't want to give away
any of the secrets so I'm going to try
to ask I guess my first question is if
you could leave set wearing your
costumes and go somewhere in real life
where would you go and why Taco Bell
very fast shock value yeah get a Cheesy
Gordita Crunch Crunchwrap Supreme
fold fully decked out yeah use my Cape
as like a napkin yeah oh God I don't
know where would I go where's the street
where all the superheroes go
Hollywood Boulevard Hollywood Boulevard
to Hollywood Boulevard and I'd be like
I'm one of them
I'm one of you you know I'm lazy I would
go home I would go home I would go to my
couch where I always go with extra
padding I could just sleep sleep more
comfortably interesting that sounds fun
I'm actually envisioning the three of
you on Hollywood Boulevard like
promoting the movie in costume it'd be
so fun it's not a bad idea probably make
some extra coins
exactly I'll do it that'd be good
marketing I think yeah I definitely want
to ask you an individual question you
are the only one who gets to be in both
worlds if you will
um what was it like finding out you were
going to be a superhero in the uh sequel
it was so sweet I mean Mary Mary I don't
know if I can say this but from the
comic books Mary Marvel you know like
she had her comic run so to get to be in
the suit felt really
um a bit of a dream come true getting a
golden age
I got to work with everyone
playing with everybody the whole time
which is the best you know the kids and
the adults
uh just included Grace is the only adult
on and off camera she has the Corral the
younger cast so it was you know I felt
exactly like it did when it work uh I
heard Zach plays music before filming
begins or right before a scene at all
times yeah right exactly or when you're
leaving my last day he played The Winner
Takes It All by Abba and it really
touched me
I love Apple
I think I messed this thing up but I but
I am curious because he plays and
apparently like even Helen Mirren would
dance or sing or no yeah what would you
actually like onto it because this is
unusual I've been on sets this is all I
know dude it's a mess it is a positive
mess there's music the best mess yeah
um Zach was on his his one wheel yeah
I'm skateboarding
yeah video game the layer uh you're like
I want to be there you'll in the film
The layer you know there's video game
setups there's food like all that stuff
was practical and real it wasn't fixed
so we never went to our trailers we
stayed inside the lair and played Hades
were all hooked on Hades was awesome
hardcore yeah it's like the big screen
TV we attached the switch to so we would
play Mario Kart yeah
it's true to life that we ate and
popcorn and everything on those couches
it was awesome and Grace would casually
walk through just with disdain and
judgment in her eyes completely judgment
right yeah she thought she was better
than everyone yeah I was probably taking
a nap on the bean bag chair because I
was doing like with the kids and the
adults always on set so I was like okay
yeah okay who am I with today okay you
guys cool I have to rap but just who's
the best at Mario Kart
um
it's Ross Ross is better than everybody
in everything I'm a video I'm very true
to character I'm yeah I will take the
video game kid and you will and we will
hand it to you that's fair that's fair
on that note I gotta go I'm just gonna
say congrats the movie's a huge hit for
you guys thanks man thank you so much
thank you